Casttoo designs your cast with your own X-ray
And this Chinese soft-shelled turtle pees
through its mouth.
Vsauce, Kevin here. This is Mind Blow.
A Dutch design lab has conceptualized the
future highway. It features glow in the dark
roads that charge during the day and light
up at night, asphalt paint that changes depending
on the road conditions, such as snowflakes
when the roads are icy, and lanes that double
as electric car chargers. Prototypes for the
asphalt paint and glow in the dark road are
going to be implemented in 2013 on a stretch
of road in Holland.
Meanwhile, in Japan, researchers are trying
to make car interiors appear transparent.
The system applies optical camouflage technology
using video from rear cameras to project onto
the backseat, and it's all processed by a
computer to make things appear actual-sized.
Currently, only the backseat has been made
to look transparent, but the goal is to make
the cars interior completely transparent in
order to eliminate blind spots.
This is the earliest known recording of singing from April 9th, 1860, predating the
previous held record by 28 years. And it sounds
kinda scary...
The Exhale Fan is the first truly bladeless
ceiling fan. It utilizes the science of laminar
flow between an array of flat discs to efficiently
move air throughout your environment. Air
is no longer directed straight down, but moves
around the room in a 360 degree horizontal
flow and passes over you from the side like
a breeze. Check out the website for more.
Giant giraffe sculpture made of flowers.
Four teenagers created a urine-powered generator.
Presented at the Maker Faire Africa, 1 Liter
of urine creates up to 6 hours of electricity.The
system works by first separating out the hydrogen
which goes into a water filter for purification
and gets pushed into the gas cylinder. The
gas cylinder pushes the hydrogen into a cylinder
of liquid borax which is used to remove moisture
from the hydrogen gas. Finally the purified
hydrogen gas is pushed into the generator.
Half Bear- Half Dog- and extinct for nine
million years. It's BearDog!
Researchers in Japan are working on ways to
control robots with their minds. The interface
uses flashing symbols to control where the
robot moves and how it interacts with the
environment. A signal processing unit on a
computer translates the brain activity and
classifies it into a series of tasks. The
team can then instruct the robot on which
task to perform. The hope is this will help
paraplegic people who can't perform certain
tasks on their own.
MIT Game Lab developers created a new game
called "A Slower Speed of Light"- a first
person prototype game in which the speed of
lightslowly decelerates as the user progresses
though the game, bringing the effects of special
relativity down to walking speed. With no
enemies or real obstacles the game seems too
easy; but, with each piece collected by the
player, the speed of light slows incrementally.
Players experience the Doppler effect, time
dilation, the searchlight effect, the runtime
effect, and Lorentz transformation, all of which
make navigating through the game exponentially
more difficult. To check it out - fInd the
link below.
Finally, True Skin is a sci-fi short film
set in the not-too-distant future in which augmentation
is the way of life.
I'm going to leave you with a simulation of
the Sun's magnetic twisters in 3D. And, as
always, thanks for watching.